[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia enfocó su programa
sobre la actualidad francesa este mes de
marzo se cumplen tres años del inicio de
la pandemia de covid-19 un periodo
durante el cual el mundo pareció
detenerse un periodo durante el cual
muchos cambiaron de vida e incluso de
profesión las ciudades se convirtieron
en lugares hostiles y el campo y los
espacios abiertos en paraísos a los
cuales huir a lo largo de este programa
iremos al encuentro de los parisinos que
decidieron cambiar de vida e instalarse
en el campo de cómo esto ha impactado a
estas regiones Rurales pero también de
cómo fue el encuentro entre esos dos
mundos el mundo de la ciudad y el Mundo
del campo
[Música]
hasta antes de la pandemia el sueño de
los parisinos era tener un buen
apartamento en la ciudad y una buena
casa en el campo de hecho no hay que
alejarse mucho de esta urbe para estar
rodeado de verde y de calma sin embargo
con la pandemia y con el miedo que
generaban las grandes aglomeraciones
todo esto cambió y muchos decidieron
mudarse del todo al campo con el
beneficio además que trae el trabajo
remoto
marzo de 2020 París se convierte en una
ciudad fantasma inicia el primer
confinamiento
los citadinos que tienen la posibilidad
buscan escapar de la ciudad y hayan
refugio en el campo tres años más tarde
Qué ocurrió con estos parisinos que
cambiaron de vida y con la llegada de
estos Neo campesinos como cambió el
paisaje local las respuestas las
encontramos en perros
Este martes ensambló se lleva a cabo una
sesión de trabajo en casa de gryward y
regaldi él trabaja como independiente en
el sector digital mientras que ella es
guionista ambos acogen a pascalin una
empresaria que conocieron por redes
sociales
lo que tenemos proyectado era quedarnos
en París pero dado a que ambos somos
trabajadores independientes podíamos
venir a vivir al campo la idea era
cuando nos saltemos de París podemos
tomar un tren e irnos a vivir al campo y
finalmente cuando nos saltemos de ver
animales pues regresamos a París para
tener vida social Pero la crisis
sanitaria cambió sus planes por completo
el primer confinamiento llegó seis meses
después y lo pasamos aquí era Primavera
Así que fue el mejor periodo para
descubrir el campo como anécdota curiosa
nosotros nos decíamos Ay es una lástima
que en realidad no se confine un poco
más porque en realidad estábamos
bastante bien y luego cuando llegó ya la
época de regreso a clases y se hablaba
de un segundo confinamiento ahí es
cuando pensábamos en seis meses hemos
sido tan solo un par de veces al
apartamento por el que pagábamos 1400
euros cada mes entonces mejor dejarlo y
vemos que ocurre
tres años más tarde se instalaron
definitivamente en esta casa que hoy nos
hacen visitar
y este nos sirve de habitación para las
visitas y este es un diván para la
siesta
suelen invitar a sus amigos a que vengan
al campo y descubran su nuevo estilo de
vida
Vivir de manera más simple con menos
cosas ser menos Presa del consumismo
consumir lo que tenemos a nuestro
alrededor creo que eso fue algo
supremamente importante que no Hay
demasiadas cosas superfluas y esto es la
realidad creo que es el regreso a la
sencillez nuestros padres estaban un
poco asombrados por la manera en la que
hemos decidido vivir pero en realidad es
muy cool
por su parte pascalín una empresaria
local Está sorprendida por como su
región está llamando la atención
en realidad nunca anticipé que el cómic
iba a hacer que peggs se convirtiera de
un momento a otro en una especie de
tierra de acogida para todos los que ya
tenían casas aquí como Caguas y que
vinieron para confinarse y luego para
otros que vinieron justamente después
del confinamiento Durante los fines de
semana donde sus amigos y que también se
dijeron Ah pero es genial aquí y
entonces luego ellos también decidieron
comprar
tres años después Este fenómeno Neo
rural se ha amplificado en las zonas
campesinas cercanas a la capital nos
dimos cita con un agente de bienes
raíces de perros que nos muestra esta
construcción rústica que tiene además
una segunda casa anexa es el tipo de
bien que su clientela exclusivamente
Parisina anda buscando
antes del covid lo que más quería a los
parisinos eran una casa de campo pequeña
como residencia de descanso y un
apartamento grande París pero hoy esta
tendencia cambió por completo es decir
que se quedan con un pequeño apartamento
en París y en cambio compran superficies
grandes en el campo que han convertido
en su residencia principal a lo largo
del año
los precios han aumentado entre un 20%
esta casa se puso en venta por 638.000
euros Y antes del covid pedían por ella
400.000 euros
otra creciente tendencia son las
transacciones que se hacen gracias a las
redes sociales
mire por ejemplo la semana pasada
incluye una casa el jueves ese mismo día
en la noche puse una visa en instagram
el viernes por la mañana ya tenía dos
visitas y ese mismo día atendí la casa
incluso algunas personas que vieron las
fotos en instagram ni siquiera conocían
dónde quedaba perchas y a pesar de esto
me llamaron para hacer una oferta
el parque natural de pearch está a menos
de dos horas de París por carretera y a
una hora y 30 minutos en tren el aire
del campo y un patrimonio rico y variado
muy cerca de la capital aquí tiene el
castillo de Los Condes con una torre del
año 1000 aquí la llegada de los
parisinos ha sido una muy buena noticia
para hacer un balance para una ciudad
como
de 10.000 habitantes esta ahora cuenta
con 200 habitantes más unos 30 niños más
en las escuelas y de 100 a 150 usuarios
que todos los días toman el tren en la
estación de tren de no John y eso
también representa una cifra de ganancia
para los comercios que se estiman un 25%
de beneficios de los comercios de la
ciudad gracias al turismo y a los
habitantes de la isla de Francia
pero esta llegada de población también
pesa sobre las infraestructuras todos
los días los trenes regionales van
llenos desde la estación de norro y las
plazas de estacionamiento son cada vez
más escasas
nosotros desde el covid y el
confinamiento hemos tenido que
reinventar el barrio alrededor de la
estación porque los habitantes se han
ido quejando el restaurante no tiene
suficiente espacio los clientes no
tienen donde estacionarse y también
genera tensión y peleas entre la gente
estamos en plena discusión Pero la idea
es arreglar todo este año según el
Instituto francés de estadística los
parisinos abandonan la capital más no a
la región que la alberga se trata de la
isla de Francia ellos se instalan en
unos pequeños pueblos a unos 20 a 30
kilómetros de la capital y allí su
presencia ha traído una nueva vitalidad
a la economía local pero también a la
vida cultural que a veces puede ser un
poco limitada en la periferia Pero esto
también trae consigo algunos roces entre
los citadinos y los provincianos
a unos 20 kilómetros de
encontramos este pintoresco pueblo
llamado Belén
aquí hay parisinos instalados desde hace
mucho tiempo cuenta con una plaza de
Mercado un mercado de antigüedades
artículos de segunda mano y boutiques de
moda que adornan las pequeñas calles de
adoquines
y suma un total de 80 comercios para
1500 habitantes un récord en el país
sin embargo para la familia que gerencia
este Hostal desde hace más de tres
generaciones la ciudad ha cambiado
demasiado
yo nací aquí mi abuela era de aquí Así
que nunca pensé en irme a vivir a otra
parte
Solo que hoy ya no podría comprar una
casa aquí en Belén
la mitad de la semana no hay actividad
aquí en realidad hay algunas boutique de
decoración boutique de antigüedades en
realidad no es lo que necesitamos en la
vida diaria hay varias boutiques de ropa
pero no hay por ejemplo una boutique
para bebés tampoco hay un Joyero ni una
floristería Así que hay que subirse en
carro e ir hasta mamerjo para hacer las
compras
Además del aumento de precios en toda la
región los citadinos También tienen
algunas actitudes desagradables
tenemos dos categorías hay algunos que
son más bien simpáticos que son gente
bien que vienen para estar aquí en el
campo realmente pero hay aquellos que
nunca se atreverían a entrar aquí porque
no estamos a la altura de ellos En vista
de que somos un pequeño restaurante
obrero me acuerdo de una que me hizo
reír Una vez vino y estaba muy
sorprendida que incluso tuviéramos
electricidad porque somos ella no sabía
cómo decirlo unos pueblerinos
eso es lo que sucede cuando se cruzan
estilos de vida diferentes y a veces
puntos de vista contradictorios bueno es
agricultor y ganadero y se ha
acostumbrado a esta situación desde hace
un poco más de Cien años su familia
tiene ganado de vacas en perch y con
frecuencia se enfrenta a observaciones
que le hacen los recién llegados sobre
todo cuando de Ecología se trata
no buscan informarse solo buscan las
cosas que les interesa y de hecho me
parece que es una visión binaria siempre
o es negro o es blanco no todo el mundo
pero sí buena parte esta semana estaba
en una reunión con un amigo agricultor y
justo recibió una llamada porque le
estaban cortando los cetus el vecino
llamó para decirle que era un escándalo
que cortaran las ramas de los árboles
como si se tratara de cortar las ramas
de una carretera cuando en realidad se
trata de los bordes de tierra para poder
cultivar tuvo que detener todo de golpe
y la tala de madera no es el único
problema en pearch la agricultura
tradicional y sus tratamientos químicos
son abiertamente criticados por los
amateur de productos orgánicos yo
desarrollé una agricultura de
conservación lo cual quiere decir que
para destruir las malas hierbas si no se
destruyen mecánicamente Hay que hacerlo
con glifosato se nos acusa de contaminar
a nivel de carbono teniendo en cuenta
que somos el único oficio en el mundo
que también capta el carbono y tener que
justificarse también es una de las
razones para las cuales muchos
agricultores ya están que no pueden más
no solo es por cuestiones financieras
a pesar de todo este agricultor ve
también La otra cara de la moneda gente
con conciencia ecológica que aprecia los
productos provenientes de circuitos
cortos y también de la región productos
que justamente gozan de un lugar
privilegiado en los comercios y en los
restaurantes de moda del centro de
inorrón los recién llegados son una
oportunidad para el alcalde y su equipo
y más ahora que la ciudad va a abrir un
gran Centro Cultural
recuperar la abadía de San Denis que el
colegio va a desocupar para crear allí
un centro cultural queremos ser la
puerta de entrada de los turistas en
este territorio ser un lugar
culturalmente importante
mientras se crea el centro cultural los
habitantes de esta ciudad pueden ya
visitar el que una pareja de ex
parisinos abrió el año pasado en esta
mansión que los atalie están restaurando
con un holgado presupuesto instalaron
una galería de arte y un salón de té era
un viejo anhelo el poder tener un lugar
donde se pudieran hacer exposiciones de
obras de gente que uno quisiera ver
jamás hubiéramos podido abrir una
galería en París nunca jamás hubiéramos
tenido los medios para hacerlo
simplemente
[Música]
se resume en invertir en la vida
cultural de noro y traer artistas del
mundo entero al campo La idea es también
una apuesta por cambiar ese efecto
llamado desierto cultural fuera de París
y de las grandes ciudades en Francia de
lograr de alguna manera que ocurran
cosas interesantes y de apostar a que la
vida francesa de París también llegue a
los territorios y es un gran cambio que
está operando en este momento estoy
absolutamente convencido de eso es un
punto de giro pues las metrópolis
muestran su interés en las regiones
francesas luego de tres años de crisis
de Kobe 19 un cambio que llegó para
quedarse
Hemos llegado al final de este programa
continúen con nuestra programación en
France 24 y France 24.com